It's just you now.
You're alone.
No one to turn to for help.
Gotcha! The sport!
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sam. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe. I really gotcha guys, didn't I?
I was very surprised.
Is that how you would read it though?
Is it more like, gotcha, right?
I feel like it's more like, gotcha.
Yeah, that's what I got from it too.
Gotcha! People in the United States call it paintball.
Yeah. Is it called gotcha somewhere else?
It's called gotcha the sport and I don't know if gotcha is like an actual sport or if it's just more like that they couldn't use paintball at the time or people wouldn't know what that was.
So it's not just this game called gotcha.
Someone calls paintball gotcha.
Was paintball like popular at that time?
Both are irrelevant to my knowledge.
Like, you know, like, gotcha I've never heard of before and paintball being popular.
I only knew paintball like... Well, this game is what popularized paintball.
I mean, I played paintball, but like, I don't think it was ever called gotcha.
I think this is just them calling it gotcha.
Right. So just the game is kind of...
Because they could have also called it capture the flag, the sport.
Right. Yeah. You know, or capture the flag with guns.
But I do definitely think that every game should be followed by the sport.
Whatever the sport.
Right. I'm actually going to...
Baseball. The sport. I think, I was thinking about that and I think that it's to let you know that it's just a game and that it's not actually, you know, shooting people.
Okay. That's my take on it.
Yeah, that makes sense. Like it's for sport.
Yeah, it's like they're all, everyone's okay at the end of this.
That's a good idea.
Yeah, I like that. I also just think like...
We're just playing for flags. It's just necessary to have that be in the title because if you just call this gotcha, like that's weird.
Right. Just picking that up on the shelves and being like, what do you got today?
Well, I could play gotcha.
And they're like, oh, no, no, no, really, really.
What do you have? I feel like it's just a bad title personally.
It is a bad title.
And that's how we're starting this episode.
Because this is all about gotcha the sport.
And that is, as we were alluding to, it's a light gun game where you also get to use the controller, which is kind of neat.
And you're basically playing paintball as you go through like only three different stages.
But I'm getting ahead of myself.
But anyway, yeah. Okay.
Four? Maybe there's three.
Yeah, I was going to say, I'm pretty sure it's three.
And I think before we get into like gameplay and stuff like that, let's just do first impressions.
Because I feel like our audience isn't really familiar with this one either.
It's being a later light gun game.
So let's just talk about what grabbed us right from the start.
Sam? So right from the start, I thought this feels more like an arcade style shooter, you know, with a gun.
Where people just kind of pop out of different places and there's movement on it.
Almost like an on-rails kind of shooter.
But it's not on-rails because you're moving.
But also that the art is really good, I thought, in this game.
So those are really my first impressions.
My first impression was, first of all, that I couldn't play this game the actual way.
I had to emulate this because I don't have a CRT.
And I thought that it was going to be completely unwieldy.
But it actually seems to be even more, it's a better user experience if you just use like a PS4 controller
with a touchpad on the top.
Because that's how I aimed.
But yeah, I mean, it looks, the art style is fine.
It's an interesting concept.
But you're saying that's a better user experience than doing it, emulating it without the PS4 controller.
Than emulating it without the PS4 controller.
Because I did end up being able to play it with the actual zapper.
And I think that was what kind of caught my attention first.
Using the zapper while using the controller at the same time is something that we haven't done yet.
Yeah. I don't even think any of the other games you use a controller even like to select things.
Joe, was it you or Sam who suggested that in like one of our earlier episodes?
I was thinking about it. I can't remember.
I think it was me with Gumshoe.
I said that would be a cool thing to do with Gumshoe where you could jump with the A button and just shoot with the light gun.
They took your advice. Yeah.
I guess they're fans of the podcast.
Yeah. But yeah, I mean really my initial impression was just kind of, I was very intrigued by that because it was something we haven't done yet before with a light gun.
Okay. Yeah. And just to add in another way to play this game, I did emulate it because I also don't have access to a CRT in a New York City apartment.
But just because there's no space.
But I did try it with a Wiimote actually being able to hook up like the sensor bar and everything like that.
And that was interesting.
I did also try it with just like mouse and keyboard.
Yeah. That's always going to be terrible.
Just to see what that's like.
But I was actually surprised using mouse and keyboard that the hit boxes in this game are pretty weird.
Yeah. It's not necessarily like if you get the guy right in the middle that it's going to register with a mouse click.
I kept going for head shots and like I could see the blink for what the light gun is supposed to read.
And the head isn't even in the hit box most of the time.
Yeah. So I think for me that was like my first impression was just like, oh wow, hit boxes are weird.
I'll have to get used to that.
Because I did feel like in every other game, even including Gumshoe that we played, hit boxes felt very spot on because they were just kind of like the rectangle of the sprite.
So anywhere within the sprite that you hit, that would also register a hit on the enemy.
That's my thought on that.
Real quick, I just also wanted to go over that this is an LJN game.
Guys, any familiarity with LJN?
No. Not really, no.
Okay. Well, I'm sure NES, yes?
No. Okay, cool.
Thank you for chiming in.
I'm sure NES fans know that LJN makes just a series of terrible games that Cinemassacre, the angry video game nerd, he has gone on a whole rant about LJN.
Many people followed suit and stuff like that.
Here's what I'm going to say.
Okay. Because I looked through the list and I've only ever played like four other LJN games other than now this one.
I'm going to give this like, I'm going to give them a chance.
Okay. I'm not ready to say that their entire gamography on the NES is shit.
You know, like I'll play through each one and make that decision myself.
I'm not just going to say like, oh, that's a bad company.
Whereas like we've seen now a few times where Bandai just can't get it together.
Yeah. You know, like Chubby Cherub and what else did they do?
They did one of the wrestling games, tag team wrestling.
Yeah, they did Muscle. I thought they did Muscle.
Oh, Muscle, yes. Muscle, yeah.
Because of the license thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, you know, if Bandai got a chance from us, I feel like LJN should get one too.
We don't judge.
We should be judgment-free zone.
Didn't you start this out by saying LJN is a company that makes bad games?
I said that they were known for that.
Yeah, what's funny is LJN is defunct.
Acclaim Entertainment, who also like was a subsidiary of them, they're defunct.
So no one has any like grandstand against me on this.
You know, nobody can fight me on this.
But you're going to give them a shot.
The LJN fan club. To be clear.
I'm going to give them the best shot I can.
And, you know, similar to you give the best shot you can in Gotcha.
The sport? The sport, yes.
Not the saying. Not the word.
Yeah. So before we get into the game, I was just, I was looking at the manual for this one.
And there's nothing too interesting in there.
But if you go to the manual section where it tells you like game is over and then gives you like the three scenarios.
But it's actually four.
Game is over when all blasters are lost.
When the clock counts down to zero.
When your flag is carried back to the opponent's base.
And when all.
Yeah. I saw that.
It's just like when all infinitively.
When all anything happens.
And that's like a bullet later on.
It's like a weird format.
Are we sure? It's not even indented in the same place.
Are we sure that this isn't just like a bad scan?
Because I feel like we got the same scan.
I've looked at two different scans of this manual and it has both.
So I'm not.
Yeah. It's very clean.
When all black have you around it.
Yeah. I'm not above thinking that LJ and a company that I'm going to give a chance would not make a mistake like that.
They just came into like the copywriting room and it's like, okay, drop everything.
Pencils down.
We have to ship this game.
Pencils down. I was just making a room full of like thousands of people all writing the manual with pencil.
And they all make the same mistake.
Because they're going in unison.
So they're all at the same point when they get the pencils down.
I'm not.
Who thinks, and I'm gonna lean to Joe here,
who thinks that they could explain how to play Gotcha the Sport?
I can explain.
Oh, great. I could have explained.
I also could have explained.
No, you couldn't.
Not like this.
You've never explained like this before.
Man, I'm really nervous now.
So, Gotcha the Sport, you're playing with the light gun.
So, it's very similar to any of the light gun games.
You're shooting at your opponents.
The only difference is you are scrolling to the right.
Right. You're trying to get to the flag, which is all the way on the right.
It's captured the flag.
So, you're running to get the flag.
You shoot anyone that comes in your way before they shoot at you.
And in the meantime, one of your opponents is trying to get your flag,
which you can see on your map.
So, you watch as they run by.
You basically just gotta shoot them when you go by.
It's pretty damn easy to make sure they don't get your flag.
And then you run to the back, and then you win.
You get their flag back to where your flag was, and now you win.
And it all happens on a side-scrolling thing.
Always in the first person. It's like first person, and you're strafing.
You in real life strafing sideways.
And you also don't have any teammates.
Thank you for bringing that up.
That was the weirdest thing.
I remember like... I was trying to simulate all the other real wars on the NES,
where you're alone going in.
Right. But because it's just a game where you move from left to right,
and you don't have any teammates,
essentially it's just a race for you to pick up the flag,
and then head back to where your base is,
and then somewhere in the middle meet the guy
who inadvertently must have taken your flag by now,
shoot him, and then just race back.
Yeah. It's pretty much just moving right to left.
There's no strategy.
There's no guarding your flag.
Well, you do go left to right later.
Oh, that's true. Yeah, that's true.
That changes it up a lot. That is true.
And you have... When you see someone on the screen,
a little target will come up under your screen
to show that they're aiming at you,
and that's when you know, like,
I better kill them, shoot them with a paintball
before they shoot me.
Is that also necessary?
See, the thing is,
and I don't know if we were going to get to this later,
but this game is,
at least on the difficulty that I played at,
I didn't have to shoot anybody.
It takes so long for them to aim.
I'm a beginner. I'm a beginner, yeah.
I'm a beginner. You cannot die if you keep moving.
Okay. If you keep moving to the right I'm a beginner,
you will not fail,
and that's just like a whatever.
Like, I'm glad that they include modes like that,
you know, for people who are bad at games.
And then you can also try and rack up points
if that's what you're into.
But to Joe's point, yeah,
by the time you get to advanced,
that's like if you don't shoot them
within two or three seconds.
I feel like it's less than two seconds.
Wow. Yeah, I guess I'm over it.
I could be wrong, but...
No, I think I'm over it. Two seconds is a while.
That's like one, two.
Like, yeah, you got enough time to shoot down people.
I guess just with my thumb on the touchpad
acting as my reticle,
that was a bit more...
It would have taken me a lot of skill
to get everything in like less than a second.
Right, yeah. But, you know,
since we're talking about the skill levels,
you have beginner, intermediate, and advanced,
and I welcome things like that.
We really haven't had...
We've seen that the Japanese versions of games
sometimes get the easy and normal mode.
Most NES games that we've played
don't even give you difficulty options.
We get a lot of game A, game B,
which is really just...
Right. We haven't even seen game A or game B in a while.
Yeah, yeah. That was like a Nintendo thing for the launch games.
Yeah, yeah. You know, that really wasn't put into many games afterwards.
And I just...
I welcome something like this at all turns
because it's also...
It's a game that isn't your typical game
because you're using the light gun
and the controller at the same time.
So you might need to start off
using something like beginner
just to get the... Learn the concept.
Because the hitbox is so weird in this game
that I feel like if you jump right to advanced
just thinking like, oh, I'm good at Duck Hunt,
so I'll be good at this. It's like, it's not really the same.
Would you argue that...
Yeah, I mean, there's definitely...
It definitely feels...
To me, using the light gun,
I didn't notice what you guys were talking about.
Maybe because I'm not aiming as precisely
with the light gun, but I didn't notice that the hitboxes were off.
For me, it felt like if I missed,
it missed. And if I hit, it hit.
But again, like I'm just aiming for like the chest
because it's like the biggest target
and I just assumed it didn't matter.
But yeah, for the most part,
I felt like that, you know,
that aspect felt as good as Duck Hunt,
but then you're shooting with one hand
and you're controlling with the other.
So that was like what made it a little different.
And how did that feel with like using an actual,
you know, using the actual setup
of the NES controller and the light gun?
How did it feel to control both at the same time?
Honestly, I mean, since the controlling
on the actual like paddle
or whatever you call that is literally just left and right on the D-pad,
it was very...
It was pretty simple.
It was not like it got that complicated,
but it was kind of weird to have like,
I don't know, even with, if you've played other light gun games,
you're probably used to using two hands,
kind of like, you know,
like you would hold like a rifle or something.
It was a little strange using one hand,
but it wasn't...
You got the flag in your other hands.
That's true, yes. But what if you don't yet?
Sam, did you prefer being able to control
when you were moving throughout the stage
rather than clear all the enemies in this panel
and then we'll move you over to the next panel?
I kind of did it in chunks.
So I would kind of wait
until there were a bunch of enemies in the screen
and then stop and kind of focus up on them
and then keep going.
When I bet if I'd kept moving,
it probably would have been better,
but I think aiming was a little bit easier
when you were stationary.
At least I found that.
So... And it sounds like,
Sean, your strategy was just more like
keep moving forward.
I mean, not saying that's what I did.
I just realized that after playing
that, oh, I could have just let this all happen
and just keep going.
But no, I stopped every once in a while
when there were a bunch of enemies
or I see the flag getting ran back
to the other side.
So yeah, I kind of did it the way that Sam did.
And one thing to give this game credit for
is that even though there's only three stages,
they got pretty creative with those stages
and where enemies land and stuff like that.
Like, I was really surprised in the forest
when the first guy who killed me
was hidden behind a waterfall.
You don't see that coming.
And then all of a sudden you're like, oh yeah, they can be anywhere on the stage.
They don't have to just spawn in the usual places.
Some of the people that are laying on their stomach
are kind of hard to see at first two
and then someone's aiming at you
and you're like, where is that guy?
Yeah. But I did laugh, speaking of the stages,
I did laugh a little bit at the level of specificity.
Yes, yeah. Well, that's what I was about to get into.
So please get into that.
Because the first stage is forest.
You're just in a forest.
You don't need to know exactly which forest.
Then the second stage is Bronx.
The Bronx. But they also call it the ghetto,
which is really like a backhand to the Bronx.
Oh, wow. Where do they call it that?
On screen? I think it's in the manual.
Is it not? It could be.
You just had the one spot I'm looking at
that says Bronx. Yeah.
Yeah, I didn't see ghetto, but...
Maybe, okay. It's not Freudian.
But it's also... No, it is just weird, right?
It's like the selection of stages is like,
okay, so naturally you would start in a forest, right?
That's like this game's Green Hill Zone, right?
Whatever. And then the Bronx is just like,
now we're just out in the open playing paintball.
Right. Like in the city. With these giant muscular dudes with mohawks also.
Yeah, they're punks. They're not even like people who represent the Bronx.
They're like, oh no, we're just playing paintball though.
Right. But then the third stage is just winter.
Yeah. It's not even a place now.
It's just a season that you're in.
Which they got creative with again,
with the snow and stuff like that.
Right. And, you know, having different vantage points for the enemies.
But it's still just bottomed my mind
that they thought that like winter would be the ultimate end stage.
Like, you know, like, oh, where do we go next?
Back to forest.
So the introduction of the manual has this excerpt.
Whether you're in the dense green woods,
the steamy urban ghetto,
or the snow-covered winter forest,
there's only one thing on your mind.
Survival. So, yeah, they call it a steamy urban ghetto,
which is, I guess, like, not a very nice way
to talk about the Bronx.
I always believed in you, Sean.
I knew you wouldn't just make that up.
Yeah, no, all of this is,
all of this is strange because it's,
where is just regular paintball locations?
Yeah, yeah. I mean, when I used to play when I was a kid,
we just had this weird, like, unused plot of forest.
Right, but I wouldn't have minded even, like,
castle or something, you know?
Yeah, it's a video game.
Let your imagination run wild, you know?
Yeah, yeah. Instead, it's like...
Space paint. Yeah, it could only ever happen in three locations.
Everybody knows paintball only ever happens
in the winter, the forest, or the Bronx.
Yeah, the Bronx. In the forest or the winter forest.
They didn't even think to do that.
No, that's what it says in the manual.
Yeah, it says it when Sean does.
A winter forest. I just meant, like, a version of the forest
that's just covered in stuff.
Or the city forest. That's just winter.
Yeah, yeah.
Where was the Bronx forest crossover we were all waiting for?
It's like place, time, and concept.
And if you're wondering why we're talking so much
about the stages, it's because we pretty much
run out of things to talk about when it comes to this game.
This game does not offer a lot.
Well, okay. It gives you...
No. There's this thing...
We mentioned that you can tell when people aim at you.
That's cool, right?
I still wasn't sure until that moment
if you were doing a bit there or not.
No. There's a song that plays also when they aim at you.
Yeah. There were three different songs, actually,
that I thought were interesting.
No, it went in love.
I thought it was interesting. The song changed.
Like you said, when someone's aiming at you,
it's a different song. When your opponent has your flag,
it's a different song. And then when nobody has your flag...
Well, the only thing I don't like
is that when you have their flag,
but they have your flag,
you hear the song of your flag being stolen.
You don't get to hear a song
for you having a flag.
Yeah, there's no success. And it's like,
well, I'll only ever get to stop hearing this music
once I finally cross paths with this guy
and shoot him immediately.
Yeah. That's my problem with this game
is that it's just one character going one way,
another character going another way.
Eventually, they'll find a middle point,
which might not necessarily be the middle.
Like some characters move slower than us or whatever,
but eventually there's just going to be a point
where the only thing you have to do
is just shoot the guy with the flag
and then keep moving.
There's never anything about like planning
when to take down the other enemies.
So that leads me to a question I kind of have.
So what do you think could have made this a better game?
Like not like what would be a modern paintball game,
but what would be a better NES light gun paintball game?
What would they have to do?
I almost think...
So I can't remember if we talked about this
in an earlier game,
similar to what Sam said earlier,
but like I almost want one person
to be controlling the guy
and the other person to be covering them
with the light gun. I almost feel like that would be...
That'd be cool. Some game where even if the platforming is almost...
Even if the platforming is like a Super Mario game
and you can jump on enemies and whatnot,
but then maybe there's some enemies
that only the gun can take out,
some enemies only the character can take out,
and some that cross over.
And then you can kind of like plan and be like...
That is an idea. I never thought about something like that.
You can be like, all right, so you cover this area,
I'll get this area, whatever. And that's a cool co-op game.
And they include an entire map
with like where your flag is on that map
and where their flag is and stuff like that.
Why not just also include points
for where all of everybody is on the screen
and track them all as if like,
you know, here's where your teammates are.
I'm assuming in my version of this game
that I have teammates. Here's where their people are.
And then keeping in mind that like,
oh, right now there's only one guy guarding my flag,
so I should send people that way
or send myself that way,
have my AI people focus on getting the flag.
Maybe that's something you could even do
by like hitting the start button.
And like, I guess I'm going the opposite of Joe's thing
because I'm almost saying if you're going to make us use the controller,
just make us use the whole controller.
Don't worry about just the left and right thing.
Like I'm saying... Oh man, I can see this being...
Well, continue your thought.
I just think like get kind of cool with it.
Like you have A and B
almost be like commands for your team squad.
Like B could be like play more defensive.
A could be get more aggressive towards their flag.
This is a much more complex game now.
Oh, absolutely. Yeah.
But I also just think that it's a better game
because I think that they left a lot of the structure there.
Like I said, the enemies are really cool
how they hide behind things
and that they took the time to,
even if there's only three levels,
that the three levels act differently.
That's cool. But there's just not enough going on
with the gameplay loop
that doesn't stop me from just going like,
all right, just keep moving right,
keep moving right, up, there's a guy, shoot him,
keep moving right, there's a guy, shoot him,
grab the flag, and then wait till I run into the other guy.
I think that if you keep the light gun
as a part of it, though,
the amount of use you're getting
out of the controller
is really going to hamper
your light gun experience
because you get, at one point it seems like
you're going to have to put it down
and issue commands or something
on the controller.
What if you... I almost imagine it,
sorry, but I almost imagine it like,
you know, you got your gun out like this
and then in your other hand,
you're almost, you're holding it almost like a walkie,
you know, and then you're just using
like your pinky
and ring finger
to execute the B&A commands
and using,
you know, using your index
for the left and right.
Idea. Okay.
Like gun in one hand,
power glove in the other hand.
Oh, shit. Rob with the controller
on the floor. Yeah,
but really, Rob should have been the buddy
who controls the movements
and you shoot.
You're helping Rob.
This could have been a Rob game.
Yeah, it should have been a great job
for Nintendo if they could incorporate
Rob, light gun,
and an NES controller
all into one game.
That is intense.
All right, I'm glad I asked that question.
Are there any other
pressing questions?
Or statements? You know what,
I actually think I might have
another answer to Sean's question.
Okay. Because it's fun.
I think you could, another thing that would be
kind of interesting
is if you had
some like, quote unquote,
destructible objects
or just, you know, things on the screen
that you can shoot which you have like
ammo cases and stuff.
But most of them are empty
and one of them
has the flag hidden behind it.
So it's like, oh, is it behind the snowman this time?
It's different every time. So you have to stop and search
which would make it a little more dangerous
because then people are shooting at you.
The old neighborhood game
of Capture the Flag.
Right, right. Yeah, I see.
I like that. Okay.
I think with that in mind
we should go right into
the Essential Games list.
So far, not a single
Zapper game. No.
That's of course a lie. You guys know by now
Duck Hunt is
an Essential game and we really like that.
We kind of questioned
if anything else
would ever make it
onto the Essential Games list
for Zapper games. Gotcha is now
on the table
for the Essential Games list.
Sam, where do we stand?
I think that
this game
kind of like almost has a lot
going for it. You know,
it has a lot of potential
and I think
that it's
a clever take
on the light gun but I don't think
it's essential. I think that there's,
I mean, there's only three levels.
I feel like
you can really only have that much fun
memorizing what kind of enemies
are going to be there to shoot
and I don't know.
It's okay. It's not
the best game.
It's okay for a light gun game,
I guess, but I think that's all
it can be. Sean?
Alright, one thing that
I thought about,
I think about whenever we play
a light gun game
is sort of like
retroactively looking back
at Duck Hunt and why
it is essential
and
because I think
that like all these other games
are adding to it
in some way whether it's
you shoot your character
to make him jump
or you control
the screen to go and pick up
a flag or
something along
those lines but
then when I
really think about it
I just realized that it's because
Duck Hunt had such a purity
to it where there was
really only the one thing
and while it's not
that complex
it's still
fun that I think
whenever these games
come out and they add on
these little
extra things
it's really just it's not really
adding any flavor to it
it's just adding more buttons
to press and so
no, it's not essential
but that was
just my thought on
the light gun games in general
cool Joe
so Sean
you took the words kind of
right out of my mouth so I'm just going to
sort of expand a little bit
on what you said
where I feel the same way
that Duck Hunt
I think because the light gun
I think works so well
and Duck Hunt is a game
where you're just focusing on shooting
like that's it you're trying to
raise a score by shooting
and that's what's fun about it
and I think that
there can be a really cool idea
where it's like shooting is not
necessarily the primary
objective you're using
the shooting
to try and do something else
which I thought that's a really
cool thing in this game
and I did have fun
with this game but if there's
something else that you're doing
is just run to the right
and then run
back to the left that's what makes it
so it kind of falls short
where it's like I'd rather just
play Duck Hunt whereas
which I said that
about other games too so I think that
it's there's definitely
still potential out there
that a light gun game could exist
that's doing something else
than just having you shoot
that has some other objective
that's fun but then if you're
going to do that it can't be
quite so simple
as this game was
okay this is going to
sound harsh but there's nothing
to see here folks
move on
this is not
essential and I've said
more about
worse games
but the point
that I'm making here is that
there's nothing left here on the
table for anybody
to check out
no one's looking
for like I wonder if they
made like a paintball game
on the NES and what does
that play like you're just
you don't have a CRT
you probably
don't even have a zapper
you're really
going to go out and get this
stuff just to play gotcha
like even if
you bought it for Duck Hunt
to get all that stuff right
to play the essential games
list don't buy
gotcha just to
experience another
zapper game
I don't think
that there's this game
just like it's
manual is only
half you know
I so part of
me disagrees a little bit on
that though I do agree
that this isn't like that great of a game
but I think if you all
don't make your decision
based on this but if you are already
getting Duck Hunt and Hogan's
Alley and any of those other ones and a CRT
and you already have the setup to play it
I think that this is worth
picking up because it's just a small
fun aside it's probably
going to cost you like eight dollars
or something and it's
different enough
I mean I did have a fun time
and if you are a zapper
guy I would take Joe's recommendation
to heart there because he really is
the zapper guy of this
podcast he really
enjoys that accessory
and the games
that come with it so yes
I guess I'll take that back but I
guess I meant for the
normal consumer
definitely don't go out
and buy all this stuff for this
game absolutely
not you'll have
fun with this game for a few
minutes you may compete against
your friend but it's not anything
to write home about and that's
all the time we have for this
episode of Nostalgia
join us
next time for
Jaws make sure
to play yourself we haven't
done that in a while please play
along if you can
we do this
every week every Friday
but if you can't get
enough if you're like I
need more before next
Friday go to
www.nostalgiacast.com
and check out the episodes
tab we have over 70
episodes now I think
we're almost at 80 actually
by the time this podcast
goes up so that's
pretty cool and if you
just want to like say
guys I think
that's pretty cool
you can click the
contact button on www.nostalgiacast.com
and just write in
about like thoughts on
this episode previous episodes
future episodes
we'd love to shout out
and say go Bills
yeah you could do that too
or you could say that
no the Bills will never
win a Super Bowl I'm not saying
that personally I'm just saying
that you can tell Sean
that if you're
from like New England
or something and you feel
the need to tell Sean that
go for it I'm
Michael Esposito you can find me
on at Esposito Film
on Twitter and I will
talk to you soon
Bills gotcha
yeah the whole
episode was a prank
it wasn't
real alright
cool I'll
Thank you.